all right today's topic this is about
the wii spa incident remember the one
that we brought up earlier where the
woman kind of flashed herself
uh the trans woman flashed yeah her
wiener and then this lady lost her mind
i'll be clear with you it's okay
it's okay for a man to go into the
women's section
show his
around the other women young little
girls under age your spa we spa condone
that is that what you're saying
i'm i'm up here at the at the wii spa
and a man okay comes in
slinging his
i
i almost want to fall out i couldn't
believe what i saw
and you got some women
to say something baby i'm not scared to
say a thang the blood of jesus against
this walling out lying spirit no i was
like this is fake after we covered the
video everyone's thought it was fake and
i'm like it's fake apparently i'm
looking fake i saw an asian lady a
random black lady and a random white
lady complaining i said listen if they
got the justice league to complain about
this incident they did a great job
casting it but i didn't believe it was
fake anyways there's an update so
this man came in and started flashing
his jonk in front of young women it's a
korean spot if you're unaware everyone's
naked they go to one side females males
on one side and you know you go to get
massages you go to hot tubs it's kind of
like a day off for the ladies to go and
feel comfortable old women young women
whatever okay
and this transgender individual who had
all their anatomy was walking around
flashing their thing in front of kids
adults didn't give a [ __ ] okay
these women complained it turned into
the virus that you guys witnessed and
there's a nine-year-old and a 14 year
old that's never seen a penis before
that traumatized me to see that we are
women yes and that traumatized us yes no
but i'm saying we're older women we're
not little girls right we're here to
protect the little girls because it's
not it's not okay it's not and now i
can't even go and put my clothes on
because he's down there yeah and
after this
protest was happening around the spa
women were showing up saying listen
we're not against trans rights but we
don't accept the idea that people with
male anatomy be in the female section
that makes us uncomfortable tifa showed
up started actually attacking some of
these ladies
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't need that sign that sign doesn't
do anything for anyone you're just
hating on people for no [ __ ]
reasoning
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you can walk away get the [ __ ] out
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just crazy to me i don't know they
literally attack these women for saying
i don't want my young daughter i don't
want to be
witnessing the male anatomy when i'm
naked in a female only space and they
attacked them they literally physically
hit these antifa is going to antifa and
then other people came out with these
news reports and sending it to us like
yo
how could you guys report on this this
looked fake well come to find out now
that the lapd is actually filed charges
against someone and this person has a
record indecent exposure charges filed
against trans women over la spot
incident prosecutors have filed multiple
counts of indecent exposure against this
exposure this week against a transgender
woman whose alleged conduct was at the
center of a via vilia that sparked a
pair of violent protests outside of a
spa in westlake this summer darren
ajie morager was charged monday with
five counts of indecent exposure morager
has been registered
as a sex offender since 2006
as a result of convictions for indecent
exposure in 2002 and 2013. her comments
are everything about the wii spot was a
bunch of garbage and lies murray anger
said
she says she's legally female in
california and was in the jacuzzi in the
women's section where she was accosted
by kobana angel she never saw me naked i
was under water with the water all the
way up to my chest is that why multiple
women who are unrelated to each other
said they all saw you naked
i don't know
i'm probably far more reluct far more
likely to believe a bunch of women who
are unrelated to each other who all had
the same complaint felt very like
uncomfortable with you especially
considering your prior convictions for
indecent exposure just saying you still
gotta get in the spot
you gotta get in the jacuzzi and out of
it so
yeah
when you when you're on a offender's
list can you even be around young girls
you're not supposed to but then it might
vary through states what whoa she is
also facing six felony counts of
indecent exposure over a separate locker
room incident in december 2018. los
angeles county prosecutors accused
miranda of indecent exposure to women
and children in a changing area at a
swimming pool in west hollywood park
whoa
that's crazy that's crazy that is crazy
this person got a long-ass rap sheet now
look again i don't think this is
necessarily a diamond on the trans
community per se i think this comes down
to some of the fears that other people
mentioned which a lot of people said
were unjustified about the whole idea is
like if you guys remove these
protections then spaces that are only
supposed to be for females and supposed
to kept them feel safe are no longer
going to have that if people who have
the male anatomy and the male physique
end up going into those spaces i said
what i thought in the previous video so
i won't repeat all of that again today
just so i don't have to repeat what i
said before i'm gonna just splice it in
the thing that's [ __ ] up is that it's
unfortunate for for trans people at the
same time you don't want to discriminate
against a woman but you don't want to
discriminate against trans people you
don't want
to put them in a danger dangerous spot
where they have to change in a man's bed
bathroom where
it's not only discriminated against they
can
be physically harmed and you don't want
to discriminate against a woman and the
kids that's what i'm saying it's like a
uh
trans people are uncomfortable on a
day-to-day basis on an everyday basis so
you have to understand that the person
the people that are uncomfortable every
day
now you want to put some of the other
people uncomfortable and i know that's
not the lgbt you give me empty that's
just that person that did that
that's unfortunate
all right so here's the truth there's no
easy solution to this because one she
told a trans woman to go into the men's
bathroom you know blow under she did
there's a lot of unsafety lack of safety
there right because they're going into
you know that bathroom they may get
discriminated against then they go to
the women's bathroom to perceive this
certain type boy um so i recognize
that
for trans folks it's not an easy thing
to have to pick
on the flip side now we have to talk
about
safety and well-being and what it means
you know
let's take it from the kids angle i can
absolutely see that there are people out
there who would take advantage of these
new laws and walk into a bathroom for
kids and hate girls and be extra creepy
if we live in a world where so much
trafficking with so many uh dudes who
like to fondle kids with so many people
who like to of course i'm not saying
trans people out there trying to do this
weird stuff i'm saying there's people
who are posing who would
if they're willing to pick kids off the
street and off playgrounds why wouldn't
they try weird stuff like this who flash
kids so why wouldn't they do something
brazen like that especially
if it's legal to me it's a safe space
for females even though you may identify
as a woman that's fantastic and if you
want to offer life for most facets
that's fine but i think there should be
certain spaces that should be reserved
why because at the end of the day women
females have a certain fear of men
including transgender women right you
guys can understand that and there
should be safe spaces for you guys as
well so i would include a third bathroom
that's my personal opinion i think
that's the only way you make this work i
don't think there is another way other
than you know you not having the anatomy
because it just triggers something in
people that it's very real you know for
folks who have trauma and whatnot to see
somebody to flash you
you know whether intended or not it's
like
i could understand that discomfort and
that wanting to get away and so again
this is not meant to be like yo but i
got nothing like that in me
but if women are saying they feel unsafe
in these places they don't want their
kids around these spaces they don't want
their daughters
you think i think that's crazy of course
not
and
i'm not even one of those people who are
like protected people are crazy about
kids right now with trafficking and
every this is this is a a given
considering what kind of space a
bathroom in a change room is where kids
and women get undressed and change
yeah it's a very vulnerable space so i
don't think the solution is to send the
males to the men's bathroom i think it's
to create a third one that's my personal
opinion so i think there's a discussion
to be had i don't know what the solution
is y'all make your own choices i said
what i thought in the previous video so
i won't repeat all of that again today
but there's definitely a discussion we
need to stop acting like this is just a
boogeyman and some random thing because
clearly it isn't this person has been
doing this and has a rap sheet for the
last couple of years and has done this
at numerous occasions
yes
i'm not surprised where you create these
rules there's always going to be people
who are going to abuse them so we have
to find better ways of protecting
protecting folks so that's my general
thoughts but now no more stop saying
he's the boogeyman or i'll put some
transphobic hosts you need to stop
saying that everyone who's against some
of these ideas are inherently against
trans folks that's crazy
that's crazy and again just so i don't
have to repeat what i said before i'm
going to just splice it in that's it let
us know what you guys think
[Music]
m